ومع اثاره الامكانيه اعتقاله المحتمله
يبدو انه بدا حملته الرئاسيه مبكرا بشكل
موسع في مواجهه خصومه فبحسب صحيفه
بوليتيكو الامريكيه فان ترامب حول لائحه
الاتهام وشيكا الى اختبار حقيقي لاعضاء
حزبه لاسيما مع خصومه المحتملين في
انتخابات الفين واربعه وعشرين فباتت
القضيه اما الدفاع عنه او وصف من يقف عكس
ذلك
بالمتعاطف مع اليسار بالطبع في اشاره الى
الديمقراطيين الذين قالوا انه لا احد فوق
القانون حيث اتهموا ترامب باذكاء
الانقسامات السياسيه سرعان ما التقط زعماء
حزب ترامب الخيط ودفعوا عنه فرغم انتقادات
وجهها لترمت منذ ايام بسبب هجوم الكابيتال
وقف نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك
بالاضافه لزعيم الجمهوريين في الكونجرس
كيفن ارثي وكفاء ضد اي محاكمه جنائيه
لترامب وبحسب الصحيفه فان ترامب اكبر
المستفيدين من توقيت اثاره الازمه سياسيا
فهي بمثابه بدايه حقيقيه للانتخابات ازاحه
خصومه الديمقراطيين او حتى من داخل حزبه
في اشاره الى حاكم فلوريدا
الذي فضل الصمت تجاه مزاعم ترامب الاخيره